hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the balloon Roulette
challenge this is not a real gun I want
to be very clear about that
not real well technically it's a real
gun to the balloon oh yeah it's gonna
kill the blue dead yeah for sure but to
us it's totally safe yeah and harmless
and no one should ever play Russian
roulette ever and I'm joined by Aaron
from gamegrumps or egoraptor Ryan and
Madigan so say hi guys
I this copy boom boom stick has one
chamber that has a pin that is connected
to the front of it so it's cocked right
now and we spin it like this we're
supposed to spin more smoothly and
should be like more petting on Hitler it
doesn't know the half of it you kind of
it's not it'll work it'll work and then
you balloons here addley
ah yeah sake it's so scary is that run
one no I just wanted to show them how it
works and that would have sucked a bit
it would have sucked if it would have
exploded we spin it again or yeah so
each time we do it we spin it okay and
then whoever pops loses a point spinning
spinning this is true it's good tighter
than he has to it's already hot yeah you
only spin after you packed it okay P all
right just oh yeah oh yeah I all [ __ ] I
got a bit off another balloon budget you
just loses a point right like real
Russian roulette you lose a point
got scary yeah your son is there some
about like the anticipation of it no
matter what it is it was like a dog
licking your ear you do it it's good job
it's good it's like I have an irrational
fear that every time I go in the pool I
think there's gonna be a shark in there
like in the deep end okay
and it's the same irrational fear like I
know it's not a real gun but at this one
time it's just so happy to Braves this
program to be like Danger Danger Danger
no good buddy Go Go rabble oh come on
jump it's like it's like when Han Solo
and I ended months old avoid the laser
beam a PNG of his head I wasn't huh oh
you go is a edited version of the
I was really yeah you chose not to spin
the prior shopping isn't going to go in
for one we can't push the luck can only
last so whoa boy really yeah you know
what let's go on the last - it's gonna
stop now by one no then I'm not going to
FinCEN started oh that's what Matt chose
to do you realize that so it's a bad
choice it's always at the moment
oh okay so alright so now we are not
spinning it in between so I'm gonna get
a good spin
oh god there's health in just the first
one how many how many are there for six
okay
okay so now do we want to do the kill
your friends version yes okay you're
doing it to somebody okay yeah this is
the you need a friends of your name for
it this is the surprise your friends
I feel bad too quick hey come on over to
my house film video she didn't tell me
anything about it really oh maybe it's
something that's like a hole right sorry
okay okay all right safe anymore Brian
oh hey Brian milk what Ryan oh I love
everything that you're doing recently
especially like new loop here
no Aaron a big fan of the essence of
young lad bring this you said watch all
your stuff cool great work you do wanna
say that let the John Lennon
all right they're hating on me doing
illegal things
so who's that me solver from the chamber
more girl you're bad actually
oh yeah mark if it happens to me it
means something world is telling you
something I literally like I like I
wonder oh I was like I spun it already
right yes okay god oh god
Oh jack observe this but we're not
fitting after this hahaha okay alright
then we're done we're nicer my J where's
the big winners here so anyway that was
the not quiet Russians what do we call
it the happy the balloon balloon rolling
I like a little really extreme that was
happy fun everybody lives balloon
roulette
seriously don't ever this is a game a
toy don't be damaged we know you're
smart enough to understand the
difference between reality and the game
so never play with guns and this isn't a
real gun with a balloon T on the end
this is just not even a pellet gun or an
airsoft gun it's specifically made for
just this little adrenaline so don't be
stupid and thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you and right now
joining me check out their channels
respectively in the description below
and thanks again for watching now as
always we'll see you in the next one
alright sorry did you think